you are genuinely a fan of the books and
the game and everything apparently on
set you know more than anyone else
i wouldn't necessarily say anyone else
but i i am a
perfect yes i'm a big fan yeah so do you
correct
people um i don't necessarily
i'm i am effusive about getting the uh
being being
loyal to the source material let's put
it that way okay so yes yes you do
you do fly your nerd flag with pride
now one of your hobbies and he's got a
lot of them ladies and gentlemen one of
your hobbies is you paint makes you
sound weird
you do have more hobbies than the
average man i'd say but you you paint is
it war of war world of warcraft uh
warhammer warhammer i'm a fool
uh it's warhammer great okay
uh so what you see you you paint by hand
yes yeah um does everyone do that or can
you buy them reap or you know you have
to paint them but it's just how much
effort you put into it there's a lot of
everything there's the painting modeling
side of the hobby and then there's the
gaming side of the lobby okay and when
you paint them what do you do with them
then henry then you um put them together
in little armies and you fight against
someone else's army
it's actually it's it is fun oh man it
sounds ridiculous but it is yeah no toys
very good fun
do you invite people over
yeah yeah yeah okay can i come over
again
it sounds amazing
google and today are going yeah don't
ask us
please don't ask us now zendaya
you're i mean not you have an old school
hobby yeah so you knit but you do more
than knit i tried to start a new hobby
while we were shooting spider-man i got
one of those i don't know if you guys
have them but they're like um little
rugs that you can make and you basically
yarn by yarn you attach the thing and
color coordinates to like a thing i
chose puppies okay and i got about like
four squares in and i was like i'm done
with this this is too tedious for me so
i got like a little corner of a rug but
that's about it
and who taught you to knit oh my my mom
taught me to knit all i can do is scarf
so i'm not like you know i can't get you
i can't give you a sweater or like a
vest or anything but i get you a nice
thick warm scarf which is what i made
for everybody okay they're really good i
mean i loved it as a pastime i usually
like i like little tedious activities
things i can keep my br you know keep
your brain occupied and um yeah i would
i just made everyone scarfs because i
couldn't i was like what am i gonna get
everybody for christmas i was like i'll
just make them some scarves that's what
i'm doing all day yes like them or not
but we've been doing like the most
intense fight scenes on set and used to
come to set to watch quite a lot yeah
and i'll be there i'd come and have
blood all over my face i've been
fighting the goblin and i'd turn around
and you'd just be there knitting
how's your day going yeah it's good
amazing and now tom you claim this isn't
a nerdy hobby uh what are you what are
you doing here oh i'm puzzling
he's puzzling henry puzzling so it's a
jigsaw it's a jigsaw during lockdown we
just really got into puzzles and i live
with five of my friends and you know we
would kind of
every now and then you'd find someone
sitting at the table and then every
evening we'd all end up there and we'd
be just doing we'd be puzzling wow okay
not many readers in your house i see no
and unfortunately that back wall
at some point i had done you know i've
been making these spider-man movies and
people give me gifts and dolls that back
wall had become like an entire shrine
so you could see one spider-man he made
the cut he's still there yeah but the
rest had to go because it it was uh
a man was starting to haunt me a little
bit i don't want to pry but i saw this
picture earlier right what's that
let me take these glasses off so i can
see that
oh do you know what that is i think i do
[Laughter]
next quest
what is it do you know i don't know okay
we'll drive
[Music]